j'accueille maintenant laurent joffrin
l'enjeu ramon soir soit vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du nouvel
observateur producteurs à france inter
et vous avez déjà publié de nombreux
essais et vous êtes ici aujourd'hui pour
la publication de votre premier roman
on va en parler mais avant j'aimerais
qu'on dise un mot de la sphère thierry
meyssan thierry meyssan est ce garçon
que j'ai reçus dans cette émission qui a
écrit un livre qui met en doute la
version du fbi et la cia sur les
événements du 11 septembre à new york et
à washington
dans le dernier numéro du nouvel
observateur thierry meyssan est qualifié
de négationniste
par votre correspondant aux états unis
qui s'appelle philippe boulet-gercourt
alors je pas vous apprendre ce que veut
dire négationnistes ou négateurs ce sont
les gens qui nient la réalité des
chambres à gaz durant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
exemple robert faurisson faurisson est
un négationniste
alors il y aurait peut être mieux valu
dire révisionniste parce que réviser
l'histoire
même s'il est un peu tôt pour réviser
celle-là réviser l'histoire ça existe
c'est vrai dans ce hameau polémique mais
le la méthode est à peu près la même si
vous voulez dire qu'on prend à salindres
le détail qui paraissent trop blanc les
contradictions et puis on bâtit une
théorie alternative
thierry meyssan il dit moi je n'affirme
rien je mets en doute la version
officielle mais c'est pas vrai du tout
moi j'ai lu le livre mais voit aussi le
livre d'abord
et il ya le titre c'est pas un doute
c'est pas on nie pas il sait pas sûr il
ya des contradictions on dit
l'effroyable imposture
ouais l'effroyable imposture c'est une
titre un peu péremptoire et en dessous
et à marquer l'avion il n'y a jamais eu
d'avion sur le pentagone
c'est pas y at il eu un avion peut-être
qu'après il n'y a pas eu d'avion donc
c'est une c'est une une affirmation il a
une thèse contraire à celle de la thèse
de tout le monde si vous voulez c'est
pas pour ça qu'il a tort pour cent il ya
pas de complot kennedy il ya eu un
complot oui c'est aujourd'hui oui donc
la falaise et le temps à l'époque qui
disaient que kennedy n'avait pas été
nominé par lee harvey oswald été traitée
peut être pas de négationnistes à
l'époque avec un gouverneur il y avait
un procureur qui s'appelle monsieur
garrison gré à un type d'internet
c'était un procureur des états unis et
qui mettait en doute la version
officielle
là on n'est pas du tout dans cette
hypothèse les le bouquin de mes sens il
est fait à partir à sainte-thérèse au
fond des informations ou des
affirmations qui sont sur internet
depuis des semaines alors le sentiment
que j'ai c'est qu'on est en train
d'essayer de diaboliser ce thierry
meyssan et quelques années on nous
expliquait que thierry meyssan était un
type formidable il avait le réseau
voltaire y militer pour la cause
homosexuelle très bien pendant l'été il
était au parti radical de gauche temps
mais je veux dire c'est pas n'importe
qui c'est pas emmanuel ratier non plus
thierry meyssan moi je l' ai reçu le
premier ici ça met énormément reprocher
comme vous le savez tous
après moi et pas seulement pour savoir
si on pas avoir pris assez de
précautions oratoires simplement après
mois lc il a reçu 35 l'a reçu canal l'a
reçu
aurore parle a reçu finalement c'est
quelqu'un qui a été reçu par toutes les
chaînes de télévision et de radio après
être venu ici je comprends pas cette
diabolisation a priori c'est à dire
qu'on exclut tout c'est pas a priori
c'est après avoir lu le livre
moi j'ai demandé dès que j'ai eu je suis
été mis au courant de ça j'ai lu le
bouquin et j appelle correspondance
états unis il croit cependant le salut
n'est pas un agent de la cia libre s'est
passé et si il dit ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'il l'a vérifié là dessus je suis je
dire d'accord avec laurent joffrin et
pascal avant d'abord les choses se font
un peu série et non a priori et d'autre
part avant des trains lire cette idée là
était une rumeur sur internet
oui alors que je dirai tout de suite un
mot sur internet mais je crois qu'il ya
un grand danger
alice est entré comme ça brutalement la
rumeur dans la sphère publique au nom du
débat pour enrichir le débat
démocratique parce que le débat c'est
quoi c'est plusieurs perspectives sur un
même monde sur un même fait sur un même
événement mais une fois que la
distinction entre le fai et l'opinion
est en quelque sorte suspendu oublié
alors il ya plus de débat le débat meurt
il ya plus des somnambules des gens qui
arrivent chacun avec leur fait leur
version et qui se croisent et on ne peut
plus parler et je crois que ça a à voir
avec internet justement le net c'est une
belle utopie et toutes les utopies dès
qu'elle se réalise donne des enfers d
enfer très convenable c'est l'utopie
effectivement de l'égalité et de la
liberté des discours
si à l'époque si à l'époque de
l'assassinât de kennedy c'est à l'époque
du suicide de marie demeure aussi
l'époque où on nous expliquait que
françois mitterrand n'avait jamais eu la
francisque de la part du maréchal pétain
si à l'époque de mazarine tous à la
presse a mis du temps en parler c'est
l'époque il y avait eu internet soit est
vrai pas précipiter les choses soient
bien non parce que c'est vers l'internet
c'est quoi c'est tous les discours sont
des côtes où les discours sont libres
donc il n'y a plus rien yapi yapi yapi
de censure ya plus de différence ça vous
inquiète ce qui est plus de passes que
que féliciter ils font les médias
globalement quand ils vous présentent
une information il vous explique en même
temps ce qu'il faut en penser
dans ce cadre nous inquiéter ses greens
versus la même chose il ya plus personne
dont vous expliquer ce qu'il faut
entendre non non non mais ça on dit par
exemple que ben laden est un agent de la
cia
il l'est il a inauguré ses alliés de la
cia c'est comme si on disait de gaulle
c'était l'agent de churchill
non c'était l'allier et ben laden
effectivement à une période fixe bien
délimitées a été favorisée par les
américains parce qu'il voulait battre
les russes mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on
est un agent
ça c'est la vision du complot on va
aller plus loin vous brillez on a oublié
mes sens puisque va passer à une échelle
un pont se défendre 1 d'abord il n'est
pas là pour se défendre
ensuite on va passer à michel terreur
qui était sur ce plateau la semaine
dernière à michel peyrard et grand
reporter à paris match
il a dit ici il a dit ici il a dit quand
ben laden a quitté djalal abad
il a quitté djalal abad avec 150
voitures ah c'est pas le mollah omar qui
s'en va sur une moto l'a 150 voitures
donc à ce moment là il ya des satellites
américains qui voient partir ben laden
et son escorte avec 150 voitures dans le
désert afghan donc peyrard dit ça et
j'ai appelé les journaux je leur ai dit
est ce que vous aller enquêter
parce que michel peyrard c'est pas
thierry meyssan alors j'ai appelé
journal du dimanche non bancaires bien
libération on n'enquête pas le monde
jeunes et d'hermann me dis moi de façon
mon problème c'est pas d'enquêté va voir
ça avec plenel et c'est donc ça veut
dire quoi se dire qu'il ya un truc qui
dit dans une émission de télévision
devant deux millions et demi trois
millions de gens un samedi soir et le
lundi matin la presse n'en parle pas est
ce que c'est un fonctionnement normal je
vous pose la question puisque vous êtes
non seulement le patron de lov c'est
parfait comme ça parce qu'encore 30
l'émission a eu lieu avec maison n'a
enquêté immédiatement oui enfin elle a
enquêté sur les reflex inverse
est-ce que vous avez enquêté sur ce qu'a
déclaré les chiens des affaires mais si
vous me le demandez je le ferai je vous
le demande parce que si vous voulez je
trouve c'est quand même nom mais c'est
quand même sérieusement demandé vous
savez bien mais je trouve quand même que
c'est un peu grave comme ça les choses
qui sont dites et qui sont complètement
ignorées ce que je racontais la semaine
dernière c'est quand moi je disais que
mitterrand avait eu la francisque on me
traitait de blasphémateurs et puis un
jour tout gilles martinet le dise
dès 1965 c'est vrai que ça a été cachée
était connu un secret de polichinelle
ah oui alors oui c'est ce que j'appelle
un secret de polichinelle ça veut dire
l'information à deux vitesses d'un côté
et les journalistes qui savent des trucs
ils en parlent entre eux dans les dîners
tu sais mitterrand une fille qu'elle
chez elle s'appelle mazarine el abine
pour les berio et si on le dit pas et
puis cech mitterrand a eu la francisque
mais ça on lui parle du pas au bon
peuple qui achètent nos jours nous on se
dit entre nous dans les dîners donc
est-ce que l'internet c'est pas la fin
finalement de cette information à deux
vitesses ben l'information il faut
qu'elle soit enfin si c'est une
d'artisanat il faut qu'elle soit
vérifiée à la francis était un suspect
qui a franchement il suffisait de
regarder mais c'était puis il ya des
journaux il ya des journaux qui l'ont
dit d'abord beaucoup la minute qui la
vie est à l'époque quand vous dis-je
imiter celle ci se serait brisé c'est
pas des ragots qui sont dans minute en
minute était de thierry meyssan de
l'époque on pourrait dire ce qu'est ce
qui va se passer le jour le jour où il
ya un truc qui va sortir on va
s'apercevoir que dans la belle histoire
de ce que vous dites mais sans lui vend
une histoire tout emballé tout fait
comme ça qui est du prêt à acheter
le jour mais cela se remarque dans la
version de la cia et du fbi à il ya un
truc qui cloche qu'est ce qui va se
passer mais il a fait des choses qui
clochent déjà effectivement il ya des
contradictions il ya des bizarreries les
journaux qui ont parlé de ça on est les
autorités n'ont pas tout dit donc il ya
des questions qui restent posées
évidemment bien sûr mais il s'en suit
pas qu'il ya eu un complot de deux tours
de 3000 personnes pour faire croire
qu'elles payent d'avion crédible on
saute on est d'accord que l'on n'emboîte
les hypothèses dans son bouquin mais
sans ré soulève un certain nombre de
problèmes des uns des interrogations à
vous êtes d'accord là dessus puisque
vous l'avez lu il ya un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui sont soulevées et
il est traîné par hugo négationnistes
dans votre journal nous arrange ça parce
qu'ils sautent à la conclusion et qui
nie l'existence même de ces graves
quels cas d'accord c'est la polémique
j'essaie d'appeler quelqu'un de
négationniste d'accord polémique c'est
vrai enfin parler encore des sentiments
puisque je ne suis pas aussi érudit goût
mais
le sentiment que j'aime en tout cas
c'est que ce terrorisme mais c'est pour
dire quelque chose d'insupportable pour
eux parce qu'il vient pas comme ça je
pense pas qu'il ya des traditions de
terrorisme dans ces pays là depuis des
siècles je crois que les gens ont envie
de dire aussi qu'ils ont marre de
traiter comme les derniers 1 2 parce que
le racisme existe en occident depuis
bien longtemps et si on y allait
coloniser du pays c'est aussi parce
qu'on se croyait supérieurs à eux
et j'ose le dire parce que sinon
j'aimerais faire attaquer moi je n'ai
pas de bon moi je vous assure j'ai
laissé le disque de marianne un petit
appareil photo il faut y croire mais je
veux dire il faut il faut faire il faut
voir un petit peu des deux côtés et je
comprends votre passion vous vous avez
des choses à dire mais aussi faut
essayer peut-être un petit peu de voir
de l'autre côté quoi
voir de l'autre côté c'est entendre
aussi ce qu'il dit et de ce côté c'est à
côté qui dit le djihad contre la
civilisation des juifs et des croisés
alors moi je pense que la moindre des
choses justement en contenait du coeur
c'est de prendre son ennemi o o au
sérieux et de ne pas et là ce serait un
égarement de la mauvaise conscience que
de dire qu'est ce que j'ai fait de mal
moi représentants de cette citation
judéo chrétienne pour mériter ça rien ma
réponse c'est rien le virus n'a pas que
des causes dans la folie des hommes
car au risque pas des causes de social
le jihad le djihad n'écoute pas les les
lits les inégalités sociales favorise le
provoquer la propagande de terroriser
simplement et oui peut-être mais c'est
un peu embêtant
un jour j'avais eu une discussion avec
un philosophe sur carlos et carlos
venait d'être arrêté et il disait il
disait le le terrorisme c'est l'armé des
désespérés et carlos est un fils de
bourgeois extrêmement riche donc ça
tombait mal avec ben laden sa tombe
encore plus mal et avec mohammed atta
aussi donc il faut aussi prendre en
considération les u soeurs des pauvres
oui d'accord mais on peut s'en
préoccuper autrement la fin ne justifie
pas les moyens et des moyens il est
inadmissible provoque des fins elle même
inadmissible ça on peut peut-être
s'entendre là-dessus c'est assez
minimales